mais avant de lancer la discussion
définissant précisément ce qu'est un
haut fonctionnaire d'état c'est avec
flora sauvage on les trouve partout y
compris au sommet de l'état les hauts
fonctionnaires exerce à la cour des
comptes au conseil d'état dans les
ministères
certains sont mêmes membres du
gouvernement souvent énarque comme le
chef de l'état et son premier ministre
certains à l'instar d'emmanuel maquereau
ou de bruno le maire ont démissionné de
la fonction publique mais la plupart
comme edouard philippe préfère garder ce
filet de sécurité dans le monde de la
haute fonction publique
il est fréquent que des conseillers
d'état ou des inspecteurs de bercy parts
dans le privé tout en monnayant leurs
connaissances des faiblesses de l'état
en décembre dernier la cour des comptes
épinglait les salaires des hauts
fonctionnaires près de 600 d'entre eux
ont touché en 2012 plus de 150000 euros
par mois la rémunération plafond du chef
de l'état et du premier ministre au
ministère de l'économie et des finances
près de 150 cadres ont touché en 2015
plus de 150000 euros par an mais de
fortes disparités existent
l'ambassadeur de france en afghanistan
toucherait 29 mille euros nets contre
vingt mille euros pour les ambassadeurs
basés au yémen en irak ou à washington
des postes à enjeux stratégiques des
rémunérations jugées trop élevées et non
justifiés par la cour des comptes
le ministre des comptes et de l'action
publique gérald darmanin s'est engagé à
procéder sans délai aux régularisations
nécessaires et à poursuivre la réduction
des écarts de rémunération est avec nous
pour ce match des idées vincent jauvert
bonsoir et dont l'auteur de ce livre les
ans touchable d'état bienvenue en macro
née anne sophie bové vous êtes
directrice générale de l'association des
anciens élèves de sciences po rédactrice
en chef du magazine
émile vincent jauvert vous avez donc
enquêté sur plusieurs centaines de hauts
fonctionnaires le premier sujet qui
interpelle y en ad'autres on va y
revenir mais ce sont les rémunérations
expliquez-nous un peu cent cinquante
mille euros par an c'est bien cela en
moyenne en 2015
alors pour si vous voulez je me suis
intéressé à la rémunération des hauts
fonctionnaires parce qu'elle est secrète
différence d'autres pays on ne connaît
pas la rémunération des hauts
fonctionnaires et donc quelqu un ou
plusieurs personnes qui étaient
désespérés de ce fait là m'ont donné des
notes secrètes comme un peu le code
nucléaire sur d'une part les
rémunérations les hautes rémunérations à
bercy dont qui représente qui sont
au-delà de cent cinquante mille euros
par an c'est à dire le salaire du chef
de l'état il y en a 150 mais aussi une
note encore plus secrètes à françois
hollande sur le ceux qui gagnent plus
que lui dans l'ensemble de la fonction
publique qui ressent à peu près six ans
alors je ne dis pas que c'est trop j'en
sais rien c'est aux français de juger ce
qui me semble aberrant et je suis pas le
seul à le penser c'est que ce soit
secret parce que le fonctionnaire le
mieux payé de la république
d'après ce que j'ai compris ce serait le
gouverneur de la banque de france c'est
ça il semblerait 50000 euros bruts
annuels
alors oui c'est ça c'est ça plus des des
jetons de présence la banque des
règlements internationaux
anne-sophie mauvaise que ce sont des
accusations ou des rémunérations qui
vous choque qu'est ce qui vous choque
mais je moi ce qui me choque un tout
petit peu dans votre ouvrage si je peux
me permettre de le formuler ainsi c'est
que c'est un ouvrage qui est quand même
très à charge c'est à dire qu'on a qu'un
prisme pour regarder la haute fonction
publique et quand je dis à charge c'est
que déjà il faut regarder le nombre de
personnes que ça concerne d'abord on est
sur un tout petit nombre parce que quand
on lit votre ouvrage
on a tendance à refermer ce livre en se
disant mais c'est pas possible c'est
tout l'appareil de l'état
tout ça oui tous tous dans une forme de
conflit d'intérêts tous avec des
salaires donc évidemment parce qu'en
plus vous voulez vous énumérer des
quatre personnes les uns derrière les
autres
donc quand on referme ce livre
franchement il ya peu de nuances allant
ligne ans moi je peux en apporter
quelques unes il faut regarder ces
rémunérations d'abord elles touchent peu
de monde sur sur l'ensemble on a cinq
millions de de fonctionnaires on doit
avoir dans ces fonctionnaires quoi 15000
20000 hauts fonctionnaires et on parle
de six cents 600 personnes dont faut
relativiser en jute il s'agit en gros
pour aller vite de ceux qui sont nommés
à danser des ministres un donc ce biais
c'est un jeu c'est un échantillon
effectivement petit de 600 personnes
mais ce sont ceux qui tiennent
l'appareil d'état donc vous avez
parfaitement raison je ne m'intéresse
pas à l'ensemble
sans public ni même à l'ensemble de la
haute fonction publique et je voulais
c'est la très haute fonction publique
qui dirige l'état quand on ferme votre
livre on a honte parce que moi j'ai
j'allais dire j'ai un petit peu de par
ma fonction je peux faire moi même les
nuances qu'il convient et faire un petit
peu la part des choses mais pour
quelqu'un qui prend se prend ce livre il
va avoir de sérieux doutes sur la haute
fonction publique sur l'appareil d'état
une période faste ah bah oui oui j'en ai
trouvé j'ai trouvé d'abord vous parler
de sciences po pour le coup une école
que je connais bien là aussi quand je
dis pas beaucoup de nuances c'est que
vous n'expliquez pas quel est le modèle
de sciences po vous dites que le montant
de la rémunération du directeur de
sciences po non mais dites moi ce qui
est le double de celle d'un directeur
d'université
c'est ça c'est parfaitement exact on
simplement quand vous ne mentionnez pas
que nous ne sommes pas dans un jeu là
dessus complètement public
on a on n'a pas du tout le même budget
qu'une univers non non mais bon le coup
et pour le non mais quand on ne précise
pas tout lu tout le problème
on donne une vision qui est partielle et
un petit peu partial delà de la chose en
soi parce que je vous explique que
sciences po
un budget qui fait à peu près le double
de celui d'une partie par le temps qui
est financé en partie par l'état et en
partie par des fonds privés ce qui n'est
pas le cas des universités donc ne
serait-ce que de dire cela si vous
voulez la façon dont vous le présentez
impression que ce directeur de sciences
po a touché une rémunération qui est
hors des clous ce n'est pas vrai compte
tenu du modèle à l'essai la bande noire
sont ouvertes ce que je dis c'est que
l'actuel directeur de sciences po a été
choisi alors qu'il était il était très
jeune qui n'avait aucune expérience en
matière d'éducation
simplement il était conseiller d'état
comme le patron du conseil
d'administration de l'époque et quand
son prédécesseur et qu'il a été choisi
qu'entre tenez vous bien monsieur blanc
caire qui est considéré aujourd'hui
comme étant l'un des grands en matière
d'éducation était à l'époque patron de
l'essec et donc je m'interroge sur le
choix et bien raison de nous interroger
sur le choix de ce tome là à se poser
simplement sciences po aussi à l'origine
pour le coup mais on peut parler
d'autres exemples on va rester
imaginez sur sciences po faudrait juste
voilà pour safari et benjamin griveaux
parce que le problème moi je le connais
pas jean marie
donc j'en parle de manière très à l'aise
mais la façon dont vous présentez les
choses aussi pose question va y venir
parce que c'est un autre sujet c'est le
conflit d'intérêt juste eh oui pour
savoir si cette situation est une
exception française cette question des
rémunérations on s'est demandé combien
gagnait les hauts fonctionnaires chez
nos voisins européens effectivement en
grande bretagne l'un d'entre eux a
confié au times qu'il gagnait 243 milles
euros par an en italie dès 2014 les
salaires des hauts fonctionnaires ont
été diminués leur rémunération a été
alignée sur celle du chef de l'état soit
près de 248 euros par an j'ai
l'impression qu'on est dans la main mais
même ordre de grandeur en france et
ailleurs en europe
il me semble que la différence c'est que
ici c'était public
c'est tout ce que je dis comme je vous
l'aï dit au début différence et
campements grande transparence tout
simplement et donc parce qu'en espagne
on peut effectivement consulter très
librement les revenus nationale et en
grande bretagne aussi et donc quand
c'est fou comme dirait martine aubry
c'est qu'il ya un loup et que donc
probablement jeudi probablement parmi
les six ans où les 150 et à nagui sont
un peu trop payé c'est tout ce que je
dis et que voilà outre la question des
rémunérations il a effectivement le
principe d'une supposée caste de la
haute fonction publique je voudrais
qu'on regarde en ce sens ce qu'avait
écrit le candidat emmanuel macron
pendant la campagne présidentielle dans
son livre révolution il fustigeait je
cite les hauts fonctionnaires qui se
sont constitués en castes il promettait
d'en finir avec leur protection hors du
temps écoutons maintenant bruno le maire
actuel ministre de l'économie en 2015
lorsqu'il est député de l'eure voilà ce
qu'ils déclarent regarder ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui l'ancienne présidente
de li na qui a été licencié parce
qu'elle avait quarante mille euros de
notes de taxi qui est recasé dans un
ministère copinage et recasage voilà
aujourd'hui les deux règles de l'art et
des affaires on ne fait rien si cela
bien sûr majorité bien sûr c'est bien
pour ça que je réclame de nouvelles
pratiques politiques que je demande non
cumul des mandats est ce que je demande
que renouvelle les générations
politiques que je demande à tous les
hauts fonctionnaires qui font de la
politique l'avait dit à chaud des miss
de la fonction publique pour renouveler
les générations
anne-sophie beauvais on entend les
dénonciations les déclarations à valeur
d'exemple on a l'impression pour autant
que cela n'a pas vraiment changé
quand on lit le livre de vincent jauvert
en même temps est-ce que vous citez
comme parole des manuels macron
on commence quand même à voir j'allais
dire une concrétisation de ce qu'il
pensait à emmanuel macron je pense que
sa philosophie est assez simple il veut
casser les rentes et il le dit de
manière extrême la digue de manière
extrêmement claire pendant pendant sa
campagne moi je les ai entendus même
s'exprimer devant les étudiants de
sciences po alors qu'il était encore
communiste de l'économie de cette façon
là il faut briser les rentes ne pas
laisser les gens s'installer dans des
dents des dents des castes et là je
trouve que son projet de loi qui
s'annonce sur la fonction publique il a
touché à ce totem de la fonction
publique en posant en tout cas de vraies
de vraies bonnes questions et votre
livre d'une certaine manière les pauses
ses vraies bonnes questions
la transparence des salaires on
l'évoquait tout alors effectivement
c'est un vrai sujet le fait d'avoir un
statut avis c'est à dire d'être garantie
d'avoir quoi qu'il arrive même si on
part dans le privé la gare ferroviaire
de revenir c'est une question en tout
cas qui mérite effectivement d'être
d'être posée et de renforcer tous les
garde-fous déontologique et éthique pour
éviter les conflits d'intérêts parce que
là où vous avez raison dans votre livre
vous le mentionnez la commission
effectivement qui est chargé de
surveiller tout ça est faible en moyens
donc renforcé cesser son pouvoir ce
serait tout ça ce sont des vraies bonnes
questions
simplement elle son être il faut il faut
aller les chercher dans une espèce
d'énumération qui est quand même très à
charge je le redis tout de même anne
sophie beauvais nous dit ça va dans la
bonne direction vous votre titre je le
rappelle les intouchables des tables
bienvenue en macro ni donc pour vous et
emmanuel macron va pas vraiment dans la
bonne direction c'est alors d'abord
monsieur le maire a lui démissionné et
c'est le premier il n'a pas fait comme
emmanuel macron juste avant d'être élu
l'a fait ou d'être nommé il a fait ya
longtemps c'était le premier voilà donc
il a il ya une vraiment une cohérence
sur ce sujet comme d'autres d'ailleurs
qui ont démissionné
madame pécresse madame kosciusko morizet
lancar naquit en compris que c'était un
problème pour les français que de ce
cumul entre l'exécutif en quelque sorte
et le politique l'administration et les
politiques alors pourquoi la macro ni
parce que effectivement monsieur macron
dit que les hauts fonctionnaires
constituent une caste bénéficiant de
gros villages hors du temps mais dans la
pratique pour l'instant j'ai dis bien
pour l'instant
il a sélectionné autour de lui des gens
qui en font partie totalement que ce
soit son secrétaire-général
l'elysée son ministre son produit
ministre sa ministre des armées etc
tous sont issus des grands corps tous
ont fait des allers retours dans le
privé et tous on peuvent revenir comme
le premier ministre au conseil d'état
quand il aura perdu 10 nous précisément
pour que les téléspectateurs comprennent
bien moi c'est pourquoi ça pose tant de
problèmes cet aller retour entre le
public et le privé pour qu'on comprenne
bien je vais parler de conflits
d'intérêts soyons alors profit
d'intérêts il faut bien savoir que ce
n'est pas un délit c'est une situation
de fait par exemple madame par lee et
son mari ou son compagnon le qui est le
patron de l' agence des participations
de l'état et donc il est en charge
notamment des participations de la
france de l'état français dans des
industries de défense et l aile
portefeuille des armées elles
portefeuille désarmés et donc monsieur
le compagnon de la dame par libre
monsieur martin vial se déporte comme
andy des questions de défense
ça veut dire que l'état s'adapte aux
couples et non pas l'inversé
ça veut dire qu'ils étaient en situation
de conflit d'intérêts de fait il en
règle et de cette façon là mais il y en
a plein dans la macro ni beaucoup y en a
vous les épingler toussaint vous
épinglez effectivement je ne les épargne
pas gelé je les note n'est pas la même
chose monsieur gris voilà monsieur
prévost c'est pas une question de couple
mais oui je dis pas qu'il est en
situation confie la terre et monsieur
rivaux pas du tout je dis qu'il est que
ça fait partie de ces gens dit il était
lobbyiste il a été après dans le public
après il est revenu
oui mais j'ai dis pas que c'est un
compilateur et je dis que ça fait partie
de ces gens qui on se demande quelle est
leur leur allégeance en quelque sorte
est ce que c'est le prix où est ce que
je publie oui mais justement vous prenez
benjamin griveaux c'est pour ça que je
vous dis que c'est très compliqué quand
vous faites un focus sur soi sur
quelqu'un ou sur une situation parce que
benjamin griveaux c'est pas un haut
fonctionnaire
déjà à l'aller pas c'est pas quelqu'un
qui vient du public vous dites
d'accord mais en fait il a été
conseiller en cabinet ministériel chez
marisol touraine ils vont la santé sous
volant de voitures est il part
travailler chez unibail qui est une
société d'investissement immobilier pas
de conflit d'intérêts simplement vous
nous dites c'est quand même très
problématique ces personnes qui ont été
en cabinet ministériel et puis qui après
se retrouve à des directions des
affaires publiques
alors là j'ai envie de vous répondre je
suis pas seul à le dire vous savez que
l'arctique est ce le sénat par exemple à
voter a voté plusieurs amendements cet
été à la loi sur la lame mais c'est
justement sur la moralisation de la vie
publique demandant ce que ceux ci ne
puissent pas avoir réussi quoi le
passage direct d'un cabinet ministériel
et ses shows d'affaires publie un
secteur d'activité qui n'a rien à voir
pour le coup parce que je suis d'accord
avec vous quand on est au ministère de
la santé qu'on passe dans un laboratoire
pharmaceutique on peut on peut se poser
une vraie question là pour le coup je le
connais pas va j'en écrivais dominique
strauss kahn monsieur oui pour
s'attarder sur ya en particulier d
expliquer nous concrètement ce qui se
passe vous dites les hauts
fonctionnaires de bercy deviennent
conseillers fiscaux pour des grands
groupes privés parce qu'ils connaissent
les faiblesses des lois fiscales
il ya clairement un conflit tribal est
un exemple très proches je suis pas ici
pour moi qu'il dit en l'espèce là c'est
michel sapin qui a été deux fois mise
des finances qui le raconte dans le
livre il trouve ça absolument scandaleux
il ya un exemple très précis vous
souvenez de cette affaire de de la taxe
des 3 % sur les dividendes a été retoqué
conseil constitutionnel qui a déposé la
requête le recours contre le conseil
constitutionnel c'est un avocat
fiscaliste qui vient de bercy qui donc
qu'il connaissait cette faiblesse la
voile alors là il effectivement il ya
conflit d'intérêts c'est clair oui c'est
ce que je vous dise expert je pense que
votre livre pose de bonnes questions et
je hais je les ai numéraire oui c'est
déjà ça mais il faut aller les chercher
et être capable d'un tout petit peu de
nuance quand on quand on lit quand on
lit votre livre encore une fois mais que
qu'on renforce les garde-fous
déontologique c'est c'est une c'est une
évidence et est encore une fois qu'on
questionne ce statut du fonctionnaire
avis mais il ya d'autres cas parce que
dans le livre ou où malgré tout c'est
vous parlez de hauts fonctionnaires qui
après vingt ans dans le privé pendant 10
ans 15 ans et qui après ne revienne pas
dans la haute fonction publique mais
reviennent dans le secteur public ce qui
encore un tout petit peu différent et
c'est des questions qui ne sont pas
simples parce qu'on ne peut pas empêcher
les gens de valoriser dans une deuxième
ou troisième partie de carrière ce
qu'ils ont acquis dans une première
partie garot
donc c'est pour ça que les garde-fous
sont importants mais on peut soit une
certaine manière moi je ne peux pas en
vouloir un benjamin griveaux de partir
d'un cabinet ministériel pour devenir
directeur de la ferme bouger dans un
grand groupe est la question qui se pose
c'est que pourquoi n'y at il pas une
commission de déontologie qui fait son
travail
d'accord ça parce que les grands corps
ce dont je parle ce sont opposés à la
transformation de cette commission de
déontologie en une institution forte et
donc là on trouve bien c'est un souci
s'organiser entre eux pour que ce n'est
pas lille pour le coup et encore une
fois je n'aime pas du tout la porte
parole de la macro ni mais je trouve que
vous êtes un peu sévérac emmanuel macron
qui d'emblée a dénoncé vraiment de
manière très claire les arrange de
situer le dit dès le début du livre vous
dites il s'entoure mais regardez le
nombre de ministres qui ont été recrutés
pour leurs compétences hors de toute
autre fonction publique y en a beaucoup
voté blanc caire il ya mahjoubi à hulot
nissen
ce qui reviendrait à orly à madame donc
la liste de la santé les achats demain
et pour le coup cela sans projet son
projet de loi pour la première fois en
tout cas met sur la table quand même
cette question du statut du
fonctionnaire c'est autre chose statut
du fonctionnaire
ah bah non parce que s'ils ne
s'attaquent pas et il avait dit à
mediapart parle par exemple qu'il
s'attaquerait à halak au au grand corps
qu'il n'y aurait plus de classement de
sortie comme sa promotion le voulait de
façon à ce qu'il n'y ait plus ces grands
corps là qui ce qu'ils sont une espèce
de deux sont des princes de la
république dans son projet roger il ne
doit son projet il ne casse pas les
grands corps non je crois pas je crois
qu emmanuel macron défense est logique
de grand corps avec simplement pour une
raison d'ailleurs très simple et c'est
en ça aussi ou votre livret est vraiment
à charge c'est qu'on n'en revient pas
aux sources des concours de la haute
fonction publique qui sont très
méritocratique d'une certaine manière
regardez le système américain un système
américain si vous avez payé très cher la
campagne du président de la république
et après vous êtes nommé dans des postes
d'ambassadeurs c'est pas comme ça que
fonctionne notre haute fonction publique
et son ca ou quelque part elle et elle a
aussi des fonctions de quasi wii et
qu'il soit lu ment jamais je l'avais
szollar donnez-moi real allait rappeler
dans ce livre sur certains points de
fonction qui n'auraient 30 secondes mais
le problème c'est que quand on décide
qui seront les princes à vis de la
république à 22 ou 23 ans et le reste
les 15 premiers ou disons les un 1er mai
jusqu'à la fin des temps souhaite ça et
on va s'arrêter là merci à tous les deux
d'avoir participé à ce match des idées
je précise